[Music]
all right so one of the things that you
write about a lot is that the idea of
middle-class stagnation is actually
wrong yes we hear this all the time from
politicians for I think my whole life
that I was ever caring about politics
it's always that the middle class is
shrinking and the extremes are getting
bigger
etc etc but you actually take a
different position yeah this
middle-class stagnation thesis is stated
as if it's an established fact with no
arguments against it it's just wrong
I think you were born in the mid
seventies right 76 okay so according to
this thesis it was a it was right around
that time mid 70s
that's okay right so the american middle
class had been chugging along upward it
hits the mid 70s and then it's been
stagnant ever since so ordinary
Americans today so goes the thesis live
no better than ordinary Americans lived
when Gerald Ford was in the Oval Office
and you think is it crazy i mean i have
i'm unfortunately old enough to remember
the mid 1970s and although one's own
personal experiences shouldn't be a
basis for scientific conclusions they're
not irrelevant i know it may come from a
working-class US family i remember how
we lived in the 70s i don't know what
cars were like I remember television was
like what health care was like things
are a lot better today for ordinary
Americans and so I number years ago just
started looking into this this thesis
there are data that you can find that
the people who proposed this thesis
point to that that lends some
superficial credence to the thesis but
something that here just some of the
problems with with these data they
adjust for inflation in ways they vastly
overestimate the amount of inflation
that we've had since the mid 70s so mean
vastly under counting the growth in real
incomes since the 70s a lot of these
data will look at household incomes well
the side the typical population of the
American household has fallen since the
mid 1970s today it doesn't sound like
much but today it's about 11 percent
lower than it was in 1975
but that's actually pretty significant
so the same amount of income in a
household now is spread over fewer
people and so the individual people are
richer meaning we're just not having as
many kids that's we're not having as
many kids with we're becoming wealthier
so that now well maybe not in the last
ten years or so but for much of this
period younger people have been able to
move out of their family their parents
homes at a younger age and start the
households younger older people are able
to continue to live by themselves rather
than move in with their with their
children
the quality of goods and the variety of
goods and services that American
ordinary Americans have access to today
is astonishing compared to what it was
just 40 years ago i sexually spend a lot
of time looking at you know catalogs
from the mid-1970s you know Sears
Roebuck catalog and then you can look at
you know sears.com today and you can
look at the prices that would charge
back that course nominally they were
lower but then you just take those
prices and you divide them by the wage
that the average American earned back
then and do the same thing for the
prices today and divide it by the wage
of the average American earns today and
what you find in almost all cases is
that the amount of time it takes to work
in order to earn enough income to buy a
pair of jeans a shirt a washer and dryer
and your an airplane ticket is
dramatically less today America we don't
have to work as much today as we did
back then in order to get the things
that make our standard of living as high
as it is so today just the people that
believe in this that they just do a
great cell job I mean how did this meme
how did this idea get out there because
you hear this all the time everybody
this is one of the few things that you
hear on both sides of the aisle yes yeah
in fact I and yes I think the a lot Paul
Krugman says it all says it all the time
and I think in a way kind of backfire on
people in the left if they keep saying
it and I thought bleeped it's one thing
that that helped
drum up spa pew low support for Donald
Trump yeah you know middle-class
Americans even stagnating so let's do
something about it let's elect Trump
there's an interesting psychological
thing there because I think maybe most
people think they're in the middle like
they probably think it no matter what
like they if they're not
stitute and if they're not you know
worth 20 million bucks you probably
think basically you're in the middle
yeah so it's a way of making it about
you even if it's actually not the case
yeah you question if I'm not sure
exactly exactly why it caught why this
myth caught on and it has held on with
such tenacity this myth has been going
has been around now for 20 years it
started in the mid 1990s yeah and
there's actually an economist he's now
at Southern Miss mu and Dallas he was at
I'm an economist at the Dallas Fed guy
named Mike Cox and he's the first one
who really started looking into this
well let's let's look at various
measures of living standards let's look
at how much ordinary people are
consuming today compared to in the mid
70s it's a comma let's look at what
happens when we adjust for income using
better inflation adjusters come in what
Mike Cox found and I I my work is
derivative of Mike Hawks is that once
you start doing this this whole
middle-class stagnation thing just
crumbles into dust it's just not true
it's not to say that there are no
problems it's not to say that the middle
class wouldn't be even wealthier had
they're not they've been better policies
in place whatever you think those
policies might be but it is to say that
it's just crazy to believe that an
ordinary American or an ordinary
American family in 2018 has a standard
of living that is indistinguishable from
that of an ordinary American family in
1975 yeah do you know what basically the
economics look like if you're considered
in the middle class right now like the
economic they're really like numbers
that you look at on both sides and go
alright that's what middle class is
because I think that's part of the
problem it is this sort of amorphous
term yes yeah III don't believe that
they're I'm you know the the the the
Census Bureau among others they will
divide household income into quintiles I
don't recall what those numbers are at
the moment but a common definitions you
take the three middle quintile so you
get rid of the top 20% you were at the
bottom 20% you have the middle 60%
that's that's the middle class you know
upper middle middle middle lower middle
but the Census Bureau does something
interesting from time to time yeah so it
divides
household income into different
categories less than 15,000 15,000 and
25,000 on on up to like I think 250,000
and above and it tracks adjusting for
inflation it tracks household incomes
over time and you can in a perverse way
find in these data that the middle class
in America is disappearing right but
it's disappearing into the upper classes
if you look at the percentage of
households in America who are earning in
the lowest percentages right they're
shrinking the only only categories in
which the percentage of households in
the US are increasing or in the upper
income levels and so actually I think
the very lowest it might have ticked up
a little bit like the less than 15,000
but in the great middle they have fewer
households percentage-wise
earning in those categories today but
more earning a hundred thousand dollars
annually and above and so in one sense
yes it's freaky but it's getting richer
there's no evidence that we're getting
poor there's no evidence that it's
stagnating yeah so we talked a little
bit in an ancillary way about taxes
earlier so I'm not an economist but I'm
gonna lay out what I think is sort of a
fair tax system that's consistent with
all the ideals that we've talked about
here and I want you to either I'm gonna
blow your mind or you're gonna tell me
that I'm way off so something like this
this is what I've said a couple times is
that I'm basically for attacks flat tax
you know get rid of exemptions let's say
it's about 15% but we can we can fiddle
with the numbers but let's about 15%
I would exempt everyone making let's say
less than like 40 grand maybe even 50
grand so that they have a little more
disposable income that they can do
things which which I think is good for
them and good for the economy and then
just because I'm still I still have a
little bit of a guilty liberal in me I
would even be willing to do some sort of
progressive tax if you're over say 10
million a year or something like that
even though I know it's not right and
I'm sure you can get rid of that by the
end of this conversation but there's
still a piece of me that says that but
basically saying that for the huge vast
majority of the country
10% little exemptions maybe a little
trickery on the high end I think that's
consistent with the sort of classical
liberal idea of minimal involvement and
an equality of opportunity and what
you're all paying in and hopefully it
would cause a slimmer trimmer government
yeah so some glimmering in your eye and
say yeah I said earlier I think one of
the distinguishing features of an
economist has always asked us compared
to what right as compared to what we
have now I mean that that's it that's
close to perfect right I'll take it
right yes compared to what my actual
ideal would be given that we're going to
have taxes it's not quite my ideal I
would indeed get rid of the the the
progression yeah at that the only part
of me I think that still exists so the
way I look at the way I look at people
who earn those kinds of incomes assuming
the urnament and most of them do they
earn these incomes in the market that
means that these people are especially
good at making life better for ordinary
Americans they're especially good at
creating jobs they're especially good at
at increasing the value of my 401 K but
what would you say when people say but
they don't need a yachts and helicopters
and all that I would say they earn it's
theirs it's not up to me to say what
they they earn it's their money I can't
make an argument against that I know
it's there's you know the your system is
better than what we have now but
definitely if we're going to have income
taxation a flat tax and I'm willing to
have the exemption for the lower lower
incomes flat tax is the way to go not
only does it prevent a lot of political
chicanery you know messing with brackets
and but it's it is economically the
better system when you tax all
income-earning activities at the same
rate then the relative prices of
different types of labour services stays
the same when you have progressive
taxation you create greater distortions
in the economy and that that makes us as
annex a resonance of this economy it
makes us all a little bit less wealthy
than we otherwise we'd be because the
economy has to deal with these
distortions so what do we do about
spending because at the end of the day
that seems at least when we're talking
about this from a government perspective
that it's really all about spent
that you can tax out the wazoo and
regardless of whether that tanks the
economy or or fixes it or whatever that
that's almost irrelevant if you just
keep spending especially because the
amount of debt we have and we know we're
never gonna pay it back which is why
it's probably good that we have a lot of
bombs but that's a whole other
discussion you know because one day if
China calls in the debt you know we're
in a lot trouble but but how do you rein
in spending cuz this seems to be the
thing that all the Trump people right
they all thought he was gonna rein in
spending this is like the opposite pact
and and it's it's I think it's more than
ever before it is it is so I think the
big property question is I don't know
how to do it you can speculate about you
know changing the Constitution put in
constitutional balanced budget
amendments constitutional caps on
spending I'm skeptical of all of those
things government has many ways to get
around these these paper tiger
provisions the problem is the problem is
Americans today look to government and
they and they basically you're spending
other people's money and so if you're
spending other people's money it's easy
to spend my my former colleague Russ
Roberts hid a piece in The Wall Street
Journal many years ago entitled
something like if you're paying I'm
having steak so imagine imagine oh we
all go to a restaurant and you know the
different menu items right well if you
go to a restaurant and you and you're
picking up your part of the tab right
you you you may order steak but that's
because it's worthwhile to you and
you'll have to pay for it but you might
if you have to pay for you might or sick
you might order a less expensive dish
but if it's gonna be shake even so it
couldn't be shared right then based then
the bulk of your extra expenditure is
shared with the people you're going to
dinner with and that's true for every
person at that dinner right and so you
wind up with this bizarre circumstance
where every person acting rationally
winds up ordering too much winds up
asking of the restaurant too much we
wind up asking of our government too
much but we have to pay for the
resources do not fall out of the sky
free they're coming from somewhere and
and because we're spending too much
we're taking resources where they would
be better used and putting them where
really none of us want them to be used
but we all wind them using them and I
know you said before that an antic total
story is not you know proof of a bigger
theory but as you're saying that it
reminds I don't think I've ever said
this probably publicly before my
brothers
a party when I was a struggling comic
and I had no money you know I may be 50
bucks in my pocket I don't know I was
the best man all his friends were in
banking and lawyers and they had all had
money big rollers were at a fancy one of
the one fancy place the Borgata in
Atlantic City the one fancy you know
nice place in Atlantic City and we're
sitting around this huge table at a
really super fancy restaurant and I'm
and all the entrees are 8090 hundred
bucks and I'm looking around like you
know what am I gonna do here I was gonna
get the chicken for maybe fifty bucks or
something I'm sitting with my my
brothers one friend who also was kind of
struggling like I was and we're both
saying are we're gonna get the chicken
for 50 bucks we go around everyone's
gettin steak lobster steak lobster steak
lobster steak lobster it gets to my
friend Josh he turned he's the whole
time he's going I'm getting the chicken
for the waitress says what do you want
he goes lobster and then I just said
state like that like and it's exactly
what you're talking about
you suddenly lose concept of what's in
your pocket somehow it's gonna happen if
the bills gonna be shared then the the
the the the additional cost to you of
ordering steaks that is a tiny fraction
of the actual additional cost of the
steak and that's the problem with with
government today we have people in
Washington spending other people's money
for the benefit of yet other people and
when you do that you just get too much
too much spending we we've I don't know
a better way to say it doesn't sound
very economic I understand it but we've
lost and the ethic of respecting other
people's property once government gets
money once government officials figure
out something that they fancy is is good
and may or may not really be good which
doesn't mean necessarily it's worthwhile
but maybe a good project that doesn't
mean that therefore we should go ahead
and spend money on it there's an
insufficient connection between the
spending and the and and the and the
experience of the cost of the resources
that go into the spending how much are
you think of this do you think is not an
economic problem but a political problem
so that if a politician was to get this
right let's say there's some magical
politician out there who really
understands economics but he knows if he
goes to the Senate so I suspect Rand
Paul's kind of like this I think he
basically gets this man and he does
fight the best fight generally
that I think he can but that they guys
want to get reelected and saying to
people we're gonna spend less on you
even though you know it's it's the best
thing we can do for you actually it's
gonna free you one day and it's not
gonna take the economy and make us you
know slaves to a foreign nation all that
it just doesn't work politically because
it's not the easy answer of a bomb or I
think it's exactly right let's face it
each politician has a time frame that
extends to the next election right so in
the case of members of the House that's
only two years case of the president
that's four senators six that's not a
long time frame anything beyond that
time frame is irrelevant to that person
politically today or to make it relevant
that person has to have an ethic that is
very rare and unusual among politicians
and people with that ethic tend not to
be not to succeed in politics yeah a
handful do manage to get in but very few
so you have people without that ethic
and they're just looking toward the next
election which is that most again the
only non two years away for a House
member and so if the bills coming to two
and a half years from now if the if
whatever other costs are gonna happen
two and a half years from now or or
alternatively if if taking some action
that someone that's gonna have cost
today but but huge benefits no matter
how huge two years for now four years
for now I'm not gonna take it right
because it's it that will do nothing to
get them past that next hurdle which is
getting elected reelected so in a very
depressing sense or in a sort of
dystopian future sense are we in its
certain way are we on a pathway to
destruction no matter what if you think
about it I mean if you take that line of
thinking long enough right so we have a
sort of weak political crew dealing in
ways that are the reverse of how
economically we can be successful pretty
right like pretty much always going off
the off the cliff yeah so I despite all
that I've said I remain optimistic and
I'm not I'm not sure why right I feel
the same way I remain optimistic we we
still have a respect for private
property in the United States we're
still a very entrepreneurial culture we
still
hold politicians to some this is less
now but it's there's some level of
responsibility I say that I'm my
libertarian friends are gonna kill we
were saying I think there's something
there's something there yeah look the
political problem has always been there
I think the cost US Constitution in the
past up until about eighty years ago
maybe did serve more as a constraint
that has largely been shoved away but by
and large we've still prospered over the
past 80 years almost in spite of
ourselves so this something is something
in the American mindset there's
something in our gumption I don't want
to sound like I'm not rah-rah right but
but there's something about this society
of ours that remains remains relatively
open remains relatively free property
property rights remain relatively secure
I think we still have something of a of
a rule of law in in place and what I've
learned in the 40 or so years that I've
been pondering these issues is that a
free society is far more robust than I
once believed it to be which is not to
excuse or justify any of the abuses that
it takes but it's really robust and I
have no good sense of where the point is
I don't believe it's indestructible yeah
but I have no good sense of where the
point is where you hit that point and
suddenly things are destined to go into
the into the gutter we may be moving
there now I have a 21 year old son for
his sake I certainly hope we're not
close to that but my gosh if you look
back to the 1930s I think things will be
even worse than ideal wise govern you
know the trend of government wise than
they are today and yet we did pretty
well I'm glad that you just said ideal
wise because one of the things that I
focus on here is talking about ideas
very matter that's that's the whole
purpose of what I do do you think that
these ideas related to freedom and the
individual and lays a Fair capitalism
and all the things that we've discussed
here are taking root again because
that's how I started you mentioned my
interview with Thomas all right before
we started and I sense it and again this
is I can only tell you what I'm
personally feeling and what what I the
feedback I get and all that but I said
to Thomas or to dr. Saul I said do you
realize the the Renaissance your work is
having and I think he's kind of he's
kind of just over it personally I think
he's proud of his work they should be
yeah and of course he should be but I
think just on a personal note he's kind
of like yeah I've been doing this for a
long time and that's great
but I really sense these things are
taking root again even though the
mainstream media won't let you really
believe that and they still will always
elevate the people that are pushing a
lot of the more socialist stuff instead
of some people with some so getting back
to something I said earlier I think it
took a lot of people by surprise in the
late 1970s when the ideas for cutting
marginal tax rates dreg deregulation
took hold and I think that's because
people like Milton Friedman my my late
colleague James Buchanan had been
working years earlier in helping to
Hayek and working years early to make
these ideas sound and and accept it and
they were in place and when the crisis
of the 70s hit those ideas had an effect
no one knows the future the future is
not destined to repeat itself in the way
that it did then but there are a lot of
really good people are you you're doing
great work there are a lot of really
creative young people today push it
you're refining these ideas polishing
ideas presenting them to the general
public in new and more interesting ways
and maybe it's a Hope over experience
maybe the Hope over I don't hope over
reality but I actually believe that the
these ideas are strong I think they are
appealing and they're they are out there
and while today in our may 19 may 2018
yeah we can't see when they'll take root
but I think that they will in fact
protect us that's so that is the
optimist in you and I have that too
because otherwise how could we do what
we do right I mean if the answer if you
had looked at me 10 minutes ago and said
yeah pretty
we gotta go [ __ ] the edge then I would
have drunk had some of the booze you
have yeah about behind it it was just so
drinking right now
yes wait for Armageddon right yeah no I
I look I believe here's something like
that that I did not fully appreciate 20
years ago that I do appreciate now 20
years ago I was a more hard-nosed
economist and now ideas are really
irrelevant they don't matter that much
it's it's you know you know the the
institutional constraints I do think
institutional constraints matter they're
important but I've come to see ideas as
by far the single most important
constraint and fuel for a society then
largely affected by the work of Deirdre
McCloskey for thinking I had on me one
of my favorite hats that we went to dear
Drew's work has influenced me greatly
and her work she's not the only one but
she's done more than any other modern
economists to make the case for the role
of ideas and I think she's correct she's
correct in that so in that you must be
incredibly hopeful then because I mean I
feel the idea revolution I've toured
with Jordan Peterson now and I keep
going up there and saying there's a not
the right kind of revolution happening
we're not killing each other in streets
yet and how does that get stopped by an
idea revolution yeah and you're sorry so
at the beginning I mentioned that I came
to economics because I was impressed how
economics explained the gasoline
shortages in the 1970s so I don't
remember a few years ago you know
gasoline Obama was an office gasoline
prices or rising people are complaining
here's the importance of idea ideas
there were there were no serious calls
even the in the Obama administration to
go back to 1970 style price caps on what
energy I took that as it huh as a good
sign that's saying it won't happen in
the future but I believe the reason that
was the case is because the economists
who expelled in Friedman I think among
others who explain the devastating rolls
of price ceilings on energy those ideas
was still around they was still out
there still out there and they prevented
anyone who would propose such policy
seriously from being taken seriously and
so that though that notion of returning
to the 70's style price caps just never
got a hearing a few years ago when
gasoline prices were high
that-that-that's one data point that
supports our optimism yeah that that's
great I mean you know it takes a long
game right I mean that that's the point
it is a long game I won't talk a little
bit about regulation before before we
wrap up I had you may know him the
biology professor brett weinstein who's
been on the show and he says he's a
friend of mine he made an interesting
comment to me the other day i think
maybe he tweeted out and we discussed it
a little bit about well if you're if
you're taking the true libertarian
approach and you're against all
regulation well are you saying that you
want no regulation over the airlines for
example to have any safety regulations
or anything like that and what i didn't
have a ton of time to get into the
conversation i said i said brett very
quickly what I would say is I think
airlines are in the business of getting
people from one place to another and
they do all their due diligence and if
the idea of a government bureaucrat
coming in to make sure that this little
thing is this way as if they have more
knowledge about it than the airline
people I find that to be pretty faulty
but but we sort of left the conversation
there yeah what do you what is the right
amount of regulation as a libertarian oh
I'm in favor of huge amounts of
regulation and I'm not being facetious I
love regulation I believe the best
regulator is the market it's the
competitive market its consumers being
able to spend their money as they choose
and or not to spend it as they choose
it's the freedom of different producers
and entrepreneurs to enter markets or
leave markets as they choose it's the
competition among producers that's where
real regulation comes from the market
regulates activities you're right about
that there are instance Airlines for
example no one has a stronger incentive
to make sure that a multi-million dollar
piece of machinery doesn't just
willy-nilly fall out of the sky then the
owner of that multi-million dollar piece
of machinery namely the airlines or the
company that they're there they're
renting it from and so the competition
among the airlines the the the need for
them to protect their investments that
is a tremendous source of regulation and
it's a very nuanced source of regulation
it gets it right and it's not subject to
political control or political
manipulation so government so-called
government regulation is too often
actually deregulation in the worst sense
it's
government relieving businesses of the
need to be as responsive to consumers as
they would otherwise need to be so we
call for example a occupational
licensing and that's a form of
regulation well no it's a form of
deregulation it it dreg it deregulates
the existing producers in the market
from having to be as responsive as they
otherwise would to consumers so for
example this would be like you have to
have a license to cut hay yeah yes yeah
and so if I if I'm a hair braider or a
barber or an electrician and if this if
the government prevents people from
entering in competition with me that
makes my life easier I don't have to be
as responsive to consumers I can charge
higher prices I could supply less high
quality services and so I am deregulated
in fact by that so-called regulation so
basically you would say it's the risk
you have to take to be free right so
that in other words that if you're an
electrician and I have somebody come
into my kitchen we had a little light
thing the other day not yes the guy was
licensed I guess because there's got to
be licensed what you're saying it's just
the risk that you have to take because
he doesn't want to come in here and burn
my house down nor do you want him to do
it right yeah yeah this is another
unintended consequence of so so-called
government regulation and that if people
come to depend on it too much they used
to assume whatever you call up you know
call up and say you know I need some
electrical work done in my house well we
live in a state where electricians are
regulated so this God must be okay maybe
maybe not but if you knew that was up to
you to check first of all the market
supplies all these wonderful ways of
verifying quality so if anyone was free
to practice being an electrician you
would have easy access a Content would
have easy access to various mechanisms
to rank various electricians by how
especially their Yelp and all the apps
and absolutely yeah so it's it's it's a
it's a total myth to think that the
government is more concerned about our
welfare and our property than we are
who's more concerned about
your house than you are who's more
concerned about your personal safety and
health then you are the government might
pretend that it's more concerned or that
it somehow has deeper insight to what is
best for you but I don't buy it
I think I think young children there
they don't know their interest as well
as their parents do but once you become
an adult
the presumption must be that each of us
as an adult cares for and knows our best
interest much better than any third
party does reminded of something else
right now I think maybe I got too many
of my old economic theories from The
Simpsons because do you remember the
episode very early on with mr. burns at
the power plant and he's leaking
you know nuclear waste into the river
they get a three-eyed fish yeah and the
whole idea being if you just let
business do what it wants it's gonna
pollute the river and you're gonna be
eating three-eyed fish but that's
completely the reverse of everything
you've said yeah so what an economist
would say to that as well you know there
are some areas where your actions as a
private citizen spill over onto a
innocent third party so they have no
input so the reason people can disagree
about the proper role of government in
preventing pollution or or preventing
third party effects but so much
regulation has nothing to do with third
party effects it's simply to say you
know if you want to get your hair
braided you have to go to one of these
people that we approve you're not
allowed to go to that person over there
who does not yet have our approval well
there's no third party effect here and a
surprising amount of regulation is of
that sort yeah I mean I remember when I
bought this house and you have to have
all the people come by and the
inspectors and everything and they're
looking for these little absurd things
that I'm talking with the Builder about
and well this has to be an inch this way
over here and bah-bah-bah and it's like
well there was no answer for it I mean a
couple times I said well why is that
yeah regulate that's how it is some
someone in sacramento's said this is how
it should be and and that's how it is in
everybody so another problem with
government regulation is that it's one
size fits all and I don't care how smart
you are
or
how how much experience you have in the
past particularly are highly dinah in
our highly dynamic economy things are
always changing different people have
different risk tolerances so what I mean
one of my least favorite regulators is
the FDA there are very few third-party
effects with the FDA the FDA is a drug
regulation affects you and it prevents
you in consultation if you choose with
your doctor and most sensible people
would consult with a physician from
choosing what level of risks you're able
to subject yourself to in order to
relieve yourself of pain or to fend off
him in a death I don't believe that's
any bureaucrats business but yours you
may make a decision different than
differently than I do
but so what we all have different tastes
we all have different preferences
preferences all have different
tolerances I don't believe that it's the
government's position to say no no your
preference for risk is too great we're
not going to let you take this
experimental drug because we think it
might hurt you I don't see that's the
government's business at all at your
business right and you better get as
educated as possible I mean this is
where I would say it comes down to
education and and and but but who has a
better incentive to come and form the
educator that matter then you it's your
life yeah right and yes you can tell
stories well you know maybe you won't
but I can tell stories too well how do
you know that this bureaucrat over here
is gonna do as good a job I'm willing to
bet that you are much less likely to be
less careful yeah with your life then
this guy or gal is with your life yeah
all right so since you said it was a
long game and I know how much Hayek has
influenced you and you right at Caffe
Hayek calm let's just what are the ideas
of Hayek I know we've actually explored
a lot of them here but if there was
something that I told you before that a
lot of my audience they go out and they
they get books after and they start
reading on all of this what are some of
the ideas of Hayek that you would like
to impart that society is vastly more
complex than we understand it to be
particularly a market-oriented global
society you know we talked about in
determine talk about the labor market
the amount of trade you know the the GDP
numbers all these terms and numbers mask
enormous underlying complexities all the
action that makes our society work is
done at the local level and that that's
a core Hayekian insight and if you start
acting at this at the at the higher
level the risk is that that you will
stamp out you'll you'll stop out you'll
smother these individual adjustments at
the local level that actually but who's
consequence is bubble up to the top to
to make it all work there's a great
Hayek he's not the most quotable of of
guys but it's a great higher quotation
I'm not gonna get it exactly right but
it goes something like the curious task
of the Economist is to remind men of how
little they know about what they imagine
they can create right so you know we can
imagine Bernie Sanders imagines he can
create a world of everybody gets paid at
least $15 an hour those other people
imagine they can create a world in which
in which no one is dies because of you
know a drug overdose or well you can't
create that world it's far too complex
and that's the that's the critical
hijacking and inside the world for
really complex and therefore for truly
complex we want to devolve
decision-making authority down to the
lowest possible level and not have
people who are slathered in hubris
making decisions for those of us on the
ground on that note I think you're an
excellent communicator of those ideas
that's what it's all about right and
it's reciprocated yeah thank you very
much and for more on Don check out cafe
Hayek com
you
[Music]